[Musique pop rock.]
...
-Quel est le premier train
qui vous fera danser ?
Venez danser tous le locomotion.
Invitez les copains
qui savent bien twister.
Venez danser tous le locomotion.
Vous allez droit devant
et puis vous reculez.
Vous twistez en marchant,
ce n'est pas compliqué.
Venez danser tous le locomotion.
Si vous avez un bon ticker.
Alors, allez-y,
venez danser !
Pour tous bagages
quelqu'un qui vous plaît.
Attention au départ,
il faut vous dépêcher.
Venez danser tous le locomotion.
Il est déjà trop tard,
le train va démarrer.
Venez danser tous le locomotion.
Messieurs les voyageurs,
prenez le train de nuit,
jusqu'à la dernière heure,
jusqu'au dernier whisky.
Venez danser tous le locomotion.
...
Prenez le bon wagon
pour bien vous amuser.
Venez danser tous le locomotion.
En courant le garçon ou la fille
qui vous plaît.
Venez danser tous le locomotion.
Et quand le dernier train
arrivera en gare,
vous quittez les copains
en leur disant bonsoir
jusqu'à demain pour le locomotion.
Si vous avez un bon ticket.
Alors, allez-y,
venez danser !
Si vous avez un bon ticket.
Alors, allez-y, twistez !
Alors, allez-y, dansez !